I want you to take a second and just take a deep breath.
We are going to be talking about evil and pain and suffering.
This may seem like it's just another lesson in the full gamut of lessons,
and you may be tired. The year is coming to an end, and
this is going to take some tenacity
to get through. I want you to pray, and I want you to pray for the next four
weeks for your students. Not that you haven't been already, but if it's
been hit or miss, I want you to really dial in on prayer this coming
week, in these next couple of weeks.
Not only that you have students probably that are coming along, and maybe are like
on the verge of making some decisions I pray that that is the case but you also have
just some students that are going to have some significant questions doubts pain
hurt brought up these next few weeks and I want you to be aware of
that before we even get started that we're gonna dive into some pretty deep it's a
pretty heavy things over the next couple of weeks and I want you to be ready for it
So as you prepare for this week's discussion on
evil, I want you to be prayerful for yourself, for your students,
and for your leaders.
So when we're talking about evil, we're actually talking about two different
approaches to how we're talking about evil.
And throughout the next couple of weeks, we're going to look at both of these
approaches. So I want you to be patient because there's two different ways that we
can do this. There is a, what we call, what I call the philosophical,
why can't I spell? We'll just call it that.
The second is the pastoral approach.
Now, the philosophical approach is sort of academic and the pastoral approach is
just what it is. It's pastoral. Okay, so we're going to look at it from both sides.
So I want you to make sure that you understand that at the starting gate, so you
don't jump the gun. Because it's important that we see it from both sides, but not
every student is going to respond to it from both sides, which is why we do it this
particular way. So this first lesson, we want students to really understand what
evil is, right? Evil is the opposite of good.
It's the opposite of God. And a lot of people will sort of assert that evil is this
sort of thing that maybe God created.
That maybe God did something where part of the whole created universe, that there's
this force called evil and it's the opposite of good and good's a thing and evil's a
thing. Evil is the absence of good.
It's a privation of good. It's sort of the same thing.
We have darkness, right? We don't have a measurement for darkness.
The measurement is light and darkness is what we call the absence of light.
And the same thing works for cold and heat.
We don't have a measurement for cold.
We have a measurement for the absence of heat, and that's what we call cold.
We call the absence of heat, we call it cold.
It's just how we describe it. Well, evil is the same way.
You remove God from the picture, you remove his goodness from the picture, and you
suddenly have what we would call evil.
And so very philosophically, kind of heady-like sort of idea is that evil
is this sort of other than Godness out there that humanity
is responsible for and we're responsible since the garden because we
actually allowed evil to permeate our world because we made the wrong
choice. We made a choice to remove God from the picture.
So evil is a stark dark reminder that we've lost our way, that
we've looked to ourselves for our own moral compass, that we've told God that
we've got this figured out and we don't need him.
So being the gracious God that he is, he said, you have free will.
You can do what you want. You can choose to go your own way.
So we did. And evil was the result of that choice.
So one way I think that your students can really grasp this idea is by the
storyteller, right? So you want someone that can tell a great story about being
lost. And for some of them, that might not be too hard to find someone that's been
lost but didn't use navigation, right?
We all have... I don't remember the last time I actually got lost because all I
gotta do is plug it into here.
But what if you had to navigate by the sun or by a compass, right?
So you have north, right? And then you have south and you have west
and you have east.
How do I know if I need to head east, how do I know which way
is east? Well, the only way in which I know where east is, is if I know
where north is. So the first thing you do when you're lost and you have a
compass or you can look at the sun, is you figure out where north is.
And once you find what's called magnetic north, then you can orient yourself and you
can figure out every other direction.
Well imagine if the compass just kept being pointed back to
you.
What would you do? You'd just be walking in circles trying to figure out where
you're supposed to go. You'd never be able to find east or west or south for that
matter. It has to be something external of you, something that's not you
to do that. So God serves as that moral compass.
So what that leads us to conclude, and this is where the philosophical piece comes
in, is the very fact that evil exists suggests
that God exists.
Think of it this way. If there is no good, then there is no evil.
So if there's no God, there's no good.
If there's no good, there's no evil.
Because if there's no good, then there's no evil.
That means there's nothing to compare it to, right?
The only way in which we understand what evil is is because we have good because we
can look at evil and go, that's not good, okay?
So if that doesn't exist, then God doesn't exist.
But there is evil, therefore there's good.
Therefore, there's the standard to which we compare good and evil to.
Therefore, God exists is kind of how that works.
Hopefully that made sense. So from a philosophical standpoint the very
existence of evil suggests that God exists
because we have a standard to which we can understand what evil actually
is okay so small group time you're going to get questions it's going to get
real real fast um so this is the point where students are going to start bringing up
probably a load of questions on you like well, why does God allow suffering?
Why does God allow good people to suffer?
Why do bad things happen to good people?
And any other variation of the question that basically says, why is there evil in
suffering?
Some of it you can probably answer as it relates to evil specifically.
Some of it you may want to table, but be careful how you table a question.
Make sure you write it down, write it in your leader's guide, your discussion guide
or wherever you have to so you can come back to it so you don't ignore the question.
But there's going to be a lot of questions.
And if you're not getting a lot of questions, your students still have the
questions. So I would suggest posing them yourself.
Ask them the questions that they're probably asking you.
So if no one says, why has God allowed suffering or why has God allowed good people
to suffer? Why has God allowed a child to die?
Why has God allowed a lot of things that we kind of look at and go, oh my gosh, what
an injustice, is what a terrible thing you ask it and see what they think
but be ready because this is going to start getting very very personal and very
deep for some students especially if they've experienced any kind of evil or
suffering in their lives